Greetings traveler. You have journeyed far for your entertaining videos of entertainment.
You have come to the right place, yay! Many laughs are to be had.
This is the Channel Awesome Youtube channel!
Here you can see our classic material, behold! New material as well.
"Bum Reviews", "Ask That Guy With The Glasses", "Video Game Confessions", anniversary specials, "Making of" Nostalgia Critics!
Make no mistake! It IS adequate.
Classic videos, new material!
Yes, YouTube. You may touch yourself with de-light.
Channel Awesome's Youtube channel!
Watch it... Because there's nothing else online.
Except "Red vs. Blue", that's pretty good.
Actually, "Honest Trailers", they're pretty funny,
"How it Should have Ended", they're f**king hilarious,
"Cinema Sins", I mean they have me laughing all the time,
Uh, God, God, "BrentalFloss", he's great, why aren't you watching him now?
Oh my God, the Angry Video Game Nerd, oh my God, I don't tell many people this, but he is ama-
(Embarrassed) Click the videos.
Yay!